the core of wildness is to say we are
bad we are evil and the only thing that
wokeness has to offer in exchange is to
brainwash Bright Young Minds like you to
believe that what you must do to improve
the world is to complain is to protest
is to throw soup on paintings you wrote
a radical moderate Manifesto It's this
idea that uh actually maybe being an
independent is probably a pretty good
idea I couldn't give less of a [__]
about diversity uh I don't think it's
important I don't need a diverse Army I
want an army that's good at killing the
enemy you are an immigrant uh you did
live in Russia uh Putin and Russia have
been all over the news but you've
written pieces where you basically have
said listen listen to what he is saying
in his own words here is why he is mad
they want to change the global world
order they don't like the fact that
America is the most powerful country in
the world the last thing I want to talk
to you about uh is Bitcoin I'm afraid
I'm gonna trigger you and their entire
Audience by saying that I get the
feeling that this is
all right guys bang bang I've got
Constantine here with me uh Constantine
you've got this viral speech uh from
Oxford that's been going around the
internet and I wanted to unpack a couple
of things that you said in there most
namely the idea that free speech is the
foundation of Western Civilization that
seems to be an idea that completely has
gotten lost can you elaborate on that a
little bit more in terms of why you
think that is the foundation of Western
Civilization
well obviously it's not entirely true in
the sense that Western Civilization
existed uh times when we didn't have
free speech in the way that we would
hope to have but my broader point is
this you know the enlightenment values
uh that are the product that create that
you know you get the Scientific
Revolution
um and the technological and scientific
progress that that we enjoy in the west
relies upon people's ability to express
controversial ideas that other people
are not going to like I mean if the the
obvious and hack example of this would
be you know the sun does not revolve
around the earth well there was a period
of time when people would get severely
punished for saying that and now we know
that it's true that is true so uh in my
opinion the success of the West relies
in part not entirely of course but in a
large part on the ability to allow the
market to decide many things and that
applies to economics but it also applies
to ideas uh I come from I was born in
the Soviet Union and later lived in
Russia and Russia and China two
countries which are obviously very
powerful in the world but they have not
been to be able to be as technologically
and scientifically successful despite
having very very bright and talented
people and part of the reason is that
you cannot do science by government
dictate you can't do research by some
apparatic or Mandarin somewhere deciding
uh what should and shouldn't be looked
into what is the right course Etc and I
think for that reason alone but there
are many others of course too the idea
that we should be able to discuss ideas
that people don't like and express
opinions people don't like is a
foundation not only of freedoms that we
enjoy but actually more importantly even
than that of the scientific and
technological progress which drives our
societies to succeed so you and I see
eye to eye on this whole idea of you've
got to be able to test a lot of things
you've got to be able to talk about a
lot of different ideas and eventually
the market will coalesce around
solutions to real problems uh and
especially when it comes to science
technology are you worried that woke
culture and cancel culture and kind of
all of these uh relatively new um you
know movements if you will are actually
putting that in Jeopardy in the west as
well you mentioned Russia and China have
kind of succumbed to the the government
oversight and prevented the free market
from really getting to those Science and
Technology Innovations is that one of
the big ideas that you're trying to push
forward is that woke culture is also
going to stifle some of that Innovation
potentially
well I mean look around if we can't
decide what a woman is how are we going
to make technological and scientific
progress and do research right and we
have the case I don't know whether it's
the case where you are but certainly in
the UK we have prominent scientists and
biologists going on TV and being asked
uh about this issue and you know that
it's controversial for them to express
an opinion about biology I know that
that is also true of other areas of
research and so I think that's really
important that we we live in a society
that is more interested in the truth
than people's feelings yeah as you were
giving this speech one of the things
that you talked about was this wokeness
movement uh really has convinced a lot
of young people that they don't have
agency that they actually should
complain rather than build or create why
do you think so many young people are
gravitating towards that is it simply
because it's easier to complain than
build or is it something else
I think it's a large number of things
and a lot of the coverage of my speech
has been you know comedian destroys
World culture with blah blah blah and
actually I don't think that's what I was
doing at all I was challenging those
young people to step up I was not saying
to them you are just woke idiots and and
there's no point talking to you I was
talking to them precisely because I
wanted to persuade them that they can be
better and that there is a better way of
doing things but as to your question why
I think there are there are many reasons
I think there are some legitimate
reasons that young people feel uh
disempowered uh again I don't know
whether this if this is the case where
you are but in the UK uh the housing
price housing crisis is a massive issue
um young people are priced out of buying
their own home and it's hard to expect
people to you know have an investment in
their society if they literally cannot
put Roots down cannot start a family
cannot pair up with someone else
cannot live where they'd like to live
Etc
so I think that's part of the problem
and if you if you if you're not if you
don't own your own home if you don't
have a family if you're not looking
after children who need you Etc uh it
becomes quite tempting to remain in that
sort of infantile adolescent state for
much longer than previous generations
would have done you know my parents had
me at the age of 20 I had my first son
at the age of 39. like that's the
difference and I'm part of this
generation too so
um that I think is part of it another
part of it you're right man look it's a
lot easier it's a lot easier to just
complain than to do stuff and of course
social media technology enables that as
well and then there's a failure of
parenting over success of generations I
mean if you think about it from a I've
been thinking about this quite a bit if
you think about it from a teenager's
point of view an adolescence point of
view
you don't really have anything of your
own you can't really go out and create
anything can you like what you can do is
say to Mom or Dad you know can I have
some pocket money and if Dad says no
well what what options do you have
really like you know in the old schools
you could in old days you could get a
paper around that's not really available
as much to younger people nowadays that
sort of thing so what are you left with
well you whine and complain until Daddy
gives you the money and daddy nowadays
will give you that money if you want and
complain long enough
um so it's the coddling it's Jonathan
height has written about this beautiful
it's the coddling of the American mind
it's
and the fact that uh as I said on Tucker
the other day we we live in a society
where adults are afraid of children and
they're afraid of young people and uh
you know increasingly with good reason I
mean if you look at the fact that if you
are uh in a position where you you
operate some kind of institution whether
it's a college or a school or a
corporation uh you know five 20 year
olds with blue hair can get together and
get you kicked out after a long and
distinguished career so we we are a
society in which young people have a lot
of power and that power mainly comes
from their ability to punish you for not
giving them what they want so why
wouldn't they use that power
how much of your ability to talk about
this stuff uh to have it resonate to
have the speech go viral is because you
are a comedian or a saturated and you're
able to kind of say things and almost be
in a protected class I think a lot about
comedians maybe some of the last people
who uh are accepted by society when they
say the truth because it makes us all
laugh versus if somebody was at a
corporate job or a politician and they
said the same exact thing uh wokeness or
the cancer culture would go after them
does that play a part of it
I know people come after me as well I I
think that again this is different in
America I'm pleased to say you know when
we were on Joe Rogan's show we went to
his Comedy Club afterwards and you could
see that you know the freedom uh that we
all associate the freedom of speech with
America is still alive and the UK is not
the case most comedians are [__] uh
and they won't say anything uh they
won't challenge The Narrative
um and that's because they're afraid and
so I don't think it's so much that the
reason I can say what I say is I don't
give a [__] man I've got my own YouTube
show that we built with my colleague
Francis from the ground up uh you know
if YouTube cancel us which they want but
if they did we'll find somewhere else
and we make it work like I don't rely on
anyone I don't need anyone I don't need
the media I don't need the mainstream
media the only thing I need is to keep
saying what I think our audience loved
the show they reward us for doing what
we do that's it I that's I think really
the truth is the only people who can
speak freely now are people who are
uncancelable to and look everyone is
cancelable you know depends what you do
of course and what you say but generally
speaking if I'm out there expressing
what I think are rational reasonable
opinions uh I'm not afraid to get
canceled not because I'm a comedian but
because I have my own thing that
protects me from that what's been
fascinating about the response is
obviously there's virality to it so that
leads to controversy and debate uh but
you've been pretty outspoken and
transparent about some of the responses
that you've gotten many of them have
been uh quite rude uh negative uh pretty
aggressive and abrasive but also not
only from Individual citizens but you
made a comment recently online where you
haven't been invited on any left-leaning
media Outlets it's pretty much only been
right-leaning media Outlets is that just
bad for their business model and so
they're kind of trying to protect their
bottom line is it something where they
don't actually want to have the debate
why do you think it is uh that there
seems to be this line in the sand on the
political spectrum and you're really
only being engaged with on one side
I'd love to know the answer to that
question man uh I really would because
you know I always joke that I identify
as politically non-binary and that's
kind of kind of where I'm at like I
don't I don't look at I I'm not a team
player in that sense I I don't want to
be on team blue or team red I try to
think about the issues independently and
I think the idea that if you have a
certain view of abortion you must have a
certain view of guns there's a certain
view of this and that I think that's
crazy to me like the how are they
connected they're not you know so I I
try to take the issues independently but
you're right we we live in a society it
seems to me at least where
um someone like me who's prepared to
challenge the right on the things that
they get wrong will still get invited on
right-wing media uh but if I challenge
the left on where they go wrong they
won't have me on
um and that is a failing uh of theirs I
think the like we just talked about
they're afraid of their audiences
they're terrified that anyone and with
any heterodox opinion is going to be
coming on and Their audience is going to
have a backlash against that uh and who
knows maybe they're right I mean if
their business model is is built on
feeding Their audience only things that
they want to hear uh they're right not
to bring me on and uh long may it
continue because shows like yours and
shows like mine are going to thrive
as you have built your show what are
some of the things that you've noticed
that you may be allowed to do other than
just speak your mind that you wouldn't
be able to do if you worked for a large
corporation are there certain types of
guests are there certain business models
what else have you seen that really
allows for kind of ultimate Freedom that
you're describing
well I I think one of them is what we're
doing right now I I actually get invited
on TV a lot nowadays and I don't do as
much of it as I used to and part of the
reason is is like once you've had this
you know we jokes like once once you've
got the heroine of a long-term
conversation why would you drop down to
methadone you know what I mean like this
is so much more fulfilling and
satisfying we're sitting here for a good
chunk of time you're giving me the space
to speak you're not talking over me
you're not trying to make me look bad
you know you let me make myself look bad
if that's what happens but that's that's
the way we do things uh and if I was
working in some sort of corporate media
you know you get three minutes to make
one point and look there's a market out
there for that and I'm not saying those
people are you know shouldn't exist but
I enjoy this I enjoy having a
conversation I enjoy really connecting
with somebody getting to know how they
think getting to them getting to know
how I think disagreeing whether it's
disagreement but doing it in a
constructive way as opposed to going for
the clickbait and and all of that so so
that is a really fulfilling part of
doing trigonometry
um for me we get to interview
Fascinating People left and right you
know we've had the Jordan Petersons and
the Douglas Murrays and all the bill
Burrs and all sorts of different uh
people comedians
stand-ups satirists authors you know
anything name it and we just sit and
learn it's amazing what a great thing to
do for a living man is to talk to people
you find interesting uh to like I I
almost I almost think it's I don't know
if you find this but I almost find that
it's very rare for me to have as
meaningful a conversation off of the
show as it is on the show how many
people get the opportunity to sit down
with a great mind for an hour and just
engage and speak and listen and and and
think about the world like to me that
that is incredibly gratifying and I
don't think if I was hosting something
on TV or if I was involved in a TV thing
I I'd get a chance to do that I feel
exactly the same and actually I've had
friends stop me at dinner and they're
like hey you're asking me questions as
if I'm on the show uh because what you
start to realize is a lot of
conversations uh they're pretty surface
level you don't actually talk about
meaningful things even if you are with
smart people when you're more social
settings and so I just tend to want to
have the more meaningful conversation
which leads to kind of better questions
so it's always funny when they remind me
hey you know it's okay to chill out and
just have a social time one of the
things I read online that I was
fascinated by is you wrote a radical
moderate Manifesto
um and it's this idea that uh actually
maybe being an independent is probably a
pretty good idea can you describe a
little bit what that radical moderate
Manifesto entails
well the radical modern Manifesto is I
think something that most people could
comfortably would have agreed on 20
years ago
um but the way that the culture has gone
is that that has changed a lot I mean to
me there are some very basic principles
um you know one of them is I couldn't
give less of a [__] about diversity uh I
don't think it's important I am a first
generation dark-skinned immigrant in the
UK I don't want to be given a leg up I
don't want to be given a hand up and I I
don't need to be a victim I want the
opportunity to compete on Merit right
and the thing that I really rail against
is when it starts to get introduced into
things where it undermines the quality
of the effectiveness or the output of
that particular thing so I don't need a
diverse Army I want an army that's good
at killing the enemy that's what I want
right I don't need a diverse comedy uh
artificially diverse comedy industry I
need the best the funniest people on
stage in front of me right and wherever
you look
the the introduction of these arbitrary
artificial targets to me uh often
undermines the quality of the end
product which I I'm against uh but you
know the other stuff is it's like I say
obvious stuff you know I want the police
to enforce the law instead of uh
policing jokes as we do in the UK and
painting their patrol cars rainbow
colors and whatever I don't think that's
what they should be doing I think there
should be uh Prosecuting criminals uh
the catching criminals Prosecuting them
and putting them in prison uh and
keeping them away from law abiding
citizens uh you know there's all sorts
of just very obvious things I invite
people to go and read the sub stack
piece that I put out uh but I think
that's something actually that the vast
majority of people could easily agree
upon until you know you were the wrong
person for thinking that you know
endlessly artificially changing the
makeup of you know the the idea that a
company's primary focus should be on
making sure they have the right number
of Russians or in other immigrants or
women or whatever to me that's so much
coolest thing I've ever heard I happen
with our YouTube channel to run a small
business we have a very diverse team and
that is because we don't care about
diversity we care if you're good enough
and if you live in a city like London as
we do you know there's a lot of people
of different types around if you hire
the best people you're going to find a
lot of them are different they're all
going to bring their own thing and that
is how it should be it's amazing how
without the Mandate you actually may end
up having a more diverse team than many
of the teams who do have the mandates
and there's been a lot of talk in the
United States about the mainstream media
will critique these technology companies
and say hey you don't have enough
diversity you don't have enough you know
ABC uh category that we think you should
have uh and then there was a study done
that actually showed that the tech
companies were more diverse than the
mainstream media outlets and so it ends
up being this thing where when you have
uh frontal offensive kind of fire it
actually is a distraction so that you
don't get return fire right if you're
constantly attacking other people there
tends not to be that much that bill
those back on you so I've always found
that fascinating where if we agree that
finding the best people is the goal
usually those organizations end up being
quite diverse and that leads me I think
to this idea of like you are an
immigrant uh you did live in Russia uh
Putin and Russia have been all over the
news but you've written pieces where you
basically have said listen listen to
what he is saying in his own words here
is why he is mad can you explain a
little bit for people especially here in
the United States who I think just get
bombarded with uh good or bad you know
evil uh or or positive where you really
took his words and I think highlighted
Nuance that a lot of Americans could
probably learn from to better understand
what the situation is between Russia
Ukraine and kind of Putin's complaints
hey guys what's going on I hope that
you're enjoying this conversation but I
wanted to interrupt for a quick second
and tell you about a brand new
conference that I'm hosting on March 4th
at the Miami Beach Convention Center the
event is called lyceum Miami and tickets
are completely free for anyone who wants
to come I'm bringing together many of
the most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramaswamy from strive asset management
ordelion and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there all right
let's get back into this conversation
well uh Putin's primary uh agenda and he
says it in his own words and Sega
Laborer of the Russian foreign ministers
expressed this many times they want to
change the global world order they don't
like the fact that America is the most
powerful country in the world they don't
like that America uh influences a lot of
policy around the world they don't like
that many countries around the world uh
have to reckon with America when they're
making certain decisions and what they
claim they want is a multi-polar world
in other words a world in which Russia
China the United States are equals of
course that is not a stable construction
and they know it for well what they want
to put it simply is to throw America off
its pedestal that is what they want they
don't like as Putin said in one of his
speeches at the end of Western hegemony
is inevitable and this is the classic
you know I don't know if you're into
Combat Sports but I've really got into
the UFC lately it's it's the Challenger
uh who who wants to throw down the
gauntlet to the champion and knock him
off his pedestal and
you know I've been making the point for
many many years that wokeness people
think it's irrelevant it's something
that only happens online and whatever
but it's not I mean the core of wokeness
is uh the direct destruction of Western
self-confidence the core of wokeness is
to say we are bad we are evil especially
straight white men but actually why
women and this and that and the whatever
you know anyone who's straight anyone
who's not it's about fundamentally
inculcating in our societies the feeling
that we are somehow you know
we're questionable and uh that is a bad
thing because what it does is it uh it's
it's like you're destroying your own
immune system and people have forgotten
the world is not some kind of Kumbaya
holding hands unicorns and rainbows
plays the world is a competitive place
it's a competition between different
civilizations and if we don't have the
confidence in ourselves if the champion
you know doesn't want to defend that
Bell if Champion doesn't want to stand
up in the cage and fight someone else is
going to come along who wants that belt
when you see Putin saying these things
why do you think it is that Western
media isn't covering it from that
perspective is it because it makes it
them uncomfortable
okay explain more
well most of them don't speak Russian
most of them don't have the time to
listen to a four-hour speech by Vladimir
puts in order to read a transcript of
one that I've made most of them don't
have Russian speakers on staff most of
them don't want to pay thousands of
dollars to have the his speeches
translated
and if you are interested in clicks
instead of the truth well why would you
care what Vladimir Putin says what what
you can say you can do one of two things
you can do what CNN does which is go you
know Vladimir Putin is The Reincarnation
of Hitler or you can do what for some
people on Fox News including Tucker and
you know I I was on his Show recently
but I disagree with him vehemently about
his coverage of requiring which has been
fact-free basically and you can go you
know it's all our fault we shouldn't
have got the you know and blame her on
America or or you know blame it on the
Democrats or whatever because that's
what gets you the clicks uh get into the
truth is hard it takes time it takes
energy
um and I just think they're not very
competent and that's mainly the reasons
that they're not giving the American
people the information that they need if
you were made president of the United
States for a year how would you interact
with Putin or respond to some of the
things that he's saying is there like a
clear path as to what you think the
United States should do
well I mean that's that's super
difficult the you know the real question
is what do you want what what outcome do
you want that's how you know what you
want to do so what are you trying to
achieve what would you like to what
position would you like to get to
I think most people in the United States
whether rightly or wrongly would say
that they want to achieve peace uh and
you know there's a strong argument that
uh maybe pursuing peace as uh kind of
the Holy Grail may not be the best
strategy but let's just say that was the
strategies to achieve peace what do you
think is the path there
well the thing is even that with all
possible respect you know I've really
enjoyed this interview and you're asking
great questions but that is kind of a
bad question because like I said this we
did an interview for my co-host Francis
interviewed me on our Channel The Day
The Invasion happened and that that that
was a you know that got a lot of people
watching it and he said like you
you said you know what how do you get
peace and I said surrender that's the
quickest way to get peace right like if
you come up to me in the street and
demand my wallet and I go what's the
outcome here that I want I want peace
okay hand over the wallet
fine you want to do that you want to I
mean the United States has the power to
make that happen if it pulls all support
from Ukraine the ukrainians will have
will I mean they'll get slaughtered and
then surrender is that what the
Americans want you want to give
America's number one enemy a win like
that and the confidence to keep going
further is that is that what you think
you think that's not going to have
long-term consequences down the line
um peace uh for its own sake is not
necessarily the the the the outcome
because you've got to think long term
and the long-term outcome here is you
want peace but what you also want to do
is to prevent further aggression because
this is we've been down this road before
you've got to remember Russia annexed
pieces of Ukraine in 2014 and nobody did
anything and guess what eight years
later they come back uh as soon as they
felt that America was had a tie off the
ball as soon as they felt confident that
they could make further inroads so uh
from that perspective I think peace is
obviously the desired goal but you've
got to think about what you're prepared
to sacrifice to achieve it
um and for my money uh you know allowing
someone to to behave in this way uh and
encouraging them to do so by letting
them roll their tanks over Ukraine would
be the worst thing that the United
States could do here so you're
highlighting a couple of the nuances
that I find fascinating about the
situation which is uh peace uh to your
point if you just surrender the United
States uh at least the public statements
is that the United States is not engaged
we're providing support to another
country uh and I think that country
would like it to be believed that uh
they are making their unilateral
decisions and so therefore even if the
United States said to them to surrender
they would not who knows if that would
happen or not
um but to your point about preventing
further future aggression that then
changes the uh chessboard a little bit
right because not only are you trying to
achieve peace in the short term but you
actually are trying to serve as a
deterrent and one of the things that
I've been very interested in uh is the
use of U.S sanctions as part of the
strategy and so what we have seen is
that the United States has obviously
gone very very hard at Russia uh
unprecedented level of sanctions but
also got Global coordination to hit them
but as we've watched that happen it's
thrown off commodity prices we've
actually seen an influx of uh trading
volume with Russia there's many other
countries like China and India who've
said we are not going to stop trading
with them we need wheat we need oil we
need these things from them and now
there's even reports starting to come
out that actually Russian oil originally
was kind of being repackaged as Chinese
oil and sold at twice the price to
Germany and other countries but now
there's places in Singapore where there
are reports coming out that literally
the tanks and the different storage
facilities are overfilled they don't
have enough space because people are
taking Russian oil and they're mixing it
or they're kind of watering it down with
other oils so that they can then sell it
on the global market without having to
say that it's Russian oil
when you start to see kind of the
nuances and the complexity is there a
right answer like that's one thing I
keep coming back to here right or is it
just all trade-offs and actually there's
a no-win situation like nobody wins when
you have these kind of global showdowns
uh I don't think that's true I I agree
with like 99 of what you said I think
you made a great Point uh I think it's
not look my favorite author at the
moment that I've reading the most is
Thomas Sol and one of his lines is
there's no Solutions only trade-offs and
I think that's of course true uh in
terms of sanctions people talk about
sanctions as if sanctions are one thing
uh I think the sanctions on energy were
quite idiotic and they're not really
hurting Russia
um
then again technology sanctions are very
effective at preventing Russia from
continuing high-tech manufacturing
making more advanced Weaponry Etc so
you have to pick and choose what you're
talking about when you're talking about
sanctions
um but in terms of uh you know there are
no winners I disagree I think uh it's
very clear that there are two winners
out of this it's the United States and
it's China they are the two winners here
uh Russia and Ukraine are both bad
losers out of this India is not
particularly happy and this is sort of I
was talking to to a an Indian
politicians recently sort of said it's a
plague on both your houses with respect
to Russia and America from their
perspective
um but yeah look I think what you're
seeing more broadly bigger picture even
if we take a step back is
um and Peter zahan is very good on this
uh you're seeing the end of
globalization
you know this idea of uh what was it
called like peace through trade or some
other or human rights through trade or
whatever [__] that the West
convinced itself about you know if we
just let Putin's cronies launder their
money through the city of London and buy
Super yachts in the west you know the
Russians they'll get civilized and they
won't be you know the usual self and
whatever and if we just you know if we
just build some factories in China and
make all our widgets there they're not
going to put a million uyghurs in
concentration camps and they're not
gonna suppress protests in Hong Kong and
they're not they're not going to remain
the Chinese Communist Party they're
going to become beautiful liberal
Democrats like all of us wonderful
people in the west and that my friend is
BS as we've just found out and we're
going to continue to find out you know
different civilizations have different
cultures
um and so that I think is the process
that's happening the global Supply
chains are breaking down we saw during
covert that like when the [__] hits the
fan uh you know the Chinese are going to
hoard the PPE they're going to hold the
antibiotics they're going to lie to you
about the virus and where it came from
and and how it's spreading and and all
of that right and and so rather than us
exporting liberal democracy to these
countries instead we're importing
Chinese style uh authoritarianism when
it comes to lockdowns and all of this
other stuff
um so the world is becoming I think
we're in for a period that that is going
to be oh it depends where you are of
course but globally is going to be quite
a challenging period of time
economically and in other ways and as
you say it's a very complex complex
situation and that's why I asked you
what you want because there may be a
right answer but it really depends on
where you want to get to when you look
at the Western perspective of the world
do you think that uh there is a loss of
confidence in the ability for the west
and specifically the United States to
kind of police the world so you're
talking about the collapse of
globalization and usually people will
talk about manufacturing and trade and
those types of things but obviously a
lot of that has thrived because of the
United States's ability and appetite to
run around the world and kind of police
as we see the fall of globalization from
the manufacturing and trade standpoint
is your expectation that we will
actually see the United States kind of
contract that appetite
um in terms of policing the world we
obviously aren't going into Ukraine we
kind of are pseudo-participating via
support but what is your expectation
kind of moving forward for how the
United States will participate in some
of these more Global or geopolitical
events well it's hard to know man
because you know unlike many other
countries the United States is still a
democracy and so you're able to elect
people who can at least try to change
the course of the country I mean I I had
obviously very profound disagreements
with uh your previous president as I do
with this one but the one thing that I
think got him elected whether you agreed
with him or not I just think it's a fact
that the one thing that Gotham elected
and interesting to to listen to Steve
Bannon talk about the strategy and the
ideas behind it was you know the the
American Elite and Western Elites more
generally are sort of trying to sell the
public on this idea of managed decline
you know we've had our time we've been
the dominant civilization in the world
and let's just you know China's coming
and and the Asian and the Africans that
you know they're going to be the future
and and we just have to manage our
decline uh and Donald Trump came in and
went uh no no no no no no we want to be
great again and you know whatever your
views on him and his policies and
whatever it's kind of irrelevant my
point is
it really depends on who you elect and
if you and who we elect here in the UK
and if we continue to elect people who
uh are unwilling to stand up for Western
Valley so are unwilling to say uh you
know that they're happy for America to
be the strongest country in the world
who who who want to talk you know like
one of the things is an outside Observer
just listening to the way the
conversations had in the United States
like I don't remember the last time I
heard someone say something I used to
hear when I was a kid like every day
which was that is un-American right it's
almost like we don't remember who we are
anymore
um and that is to me the biggest problem
it's it's the collapse and collapse in
Western self-confidence so it really all
depends on whether your country and mine
can recapture uh that self-belief and
self-confidence and look
I say this to someone who opposed the
invasion of Iraq who opposed the
invasion of Afghanistan I don't think
that it benefits the world for America
to go sticking its its finger in every
pie and sticking its finger in
everyone's business on the other hand
there are also other things going on I
mean that's why Ukraine is so different
to Iraq and Afghanistan because the
United States did not invade uh Ukraine
and this is one of the things that I
find so funny about these people who
claim to be anti-war and
Anti-Imperialist when actually what they
mean is they're Pro the Russian Empires
attempt to rebuild Itself by means of
war that is what they're actually saying
right in effect and I'm someone who
opposes that whether it's coming from
the United States invading Afghanistan
and Iraq or whether it's Russia invading
Ukraine it's kind of the same thing
going on
do you read it all into the fact that
Donald Trump uh was elected in the
United States Boris Johnson uh and even
zielinski right he's a comedian who
eventually Rose to to become the
president of a country uh those all
happened around the same time uh is
there anything that you kind of look at
as connectivity whether it was the the
mental state of uh of various uh
societies and countries all at the same
time are like it feels like there's
something that it was in the water
across multiple countries at the same
time and then they've kind of swung the
pendulum back and obviously we got Joe
Biden here in the United States and you
can kind of see the the knock-on effects
in some of these other countries
that's a really great observation a
really good question I think uh I think
there's some truth to that and I think
the truth is that the caliber of our
politicians has been in in a precipitous
decline for some time and so the only
thing that gets the American people
excited or the British public excited
about voting for somebody is that they
are outside the system
right and in Ukraine a country I know
pretty well that was kind of the same
it's not like people like zelensky is
that they really didn't like the other
guys that were the the political uh
oligarchy that existed in the country at
the time and that's why he was elected
so
I think you're right I think our levels
of dissatisfaction with our political
class as such that we are willing to
look almost anywhere to find somebody
who can come in from the outside and
Collide to us that they're going to
change things yeah one of the other
ideas that I think is tangentially
related to this that I thought a lot
about is
um for decades and decades you know
maybe even Century uh the American dream
was kind of this thing that was held up
for uh people around the world and and
quite literally their story after story
after Story of people who did all sorts
of insanely risky things to get to the
United States just for the possibility
of having economic mobility and freedom
and democracy and capitalism and all
these things but with the Advent of the
internet and Global penetration of the
internet uh and many times in many of
the developing countries there seems to
be this like exporting of the American
dream now to anybody with an internet
connection and I always talk about like
maybe a country like India where you
have you know over a billion people and
we now are starting to see literally
kids with an internet connection and a
self phone or a computer being able to
build companies and create some sort of
economic Mobility for themselves how
does that impact one I think Society but
also two who ends up getting elected to
lead those people right if you were a
country where there was no economic
mobility and there was no you know de
facto American Dream available you had
to leave but now if you can stay does
that have a major impact on the politics
of specific countries as well
it's hard to say because uh I can't
speak for the world because I don't know
many countries but certainly in Russia I
would argue that's not been the case at
all uh if you look at the fact that you
know the support for the invasion is
still quite High even though it's going
very badly for Russia
um and it's because 80 percent of
Russians get their news from TV
um you know and so that 15 the sort of
liberal people in Russia uh who get
their news elsewhere uh you know they've
all run away or become dissidents or
become you know the unofficial
opposition or whatever the overwhelming
majority of the country uh are under the
complete informational control of
Vladimir Putin and his cronies and
likewise in China it's not like you know
the Chinese give us Tick Tock but it's
not like they're all sitting there using
Twitter and Facebook
they make their own stuff and they don't
let their people access things uh that
are in English in the English language
that they don't want to and of course
the the language barrier is also a very
powerful thing you know most people in
Russian China don't speak English so
that sort of penetration I'm sure it's
having an effect but as I look around
the world right now that does not seem
to me to be what's determining who who
gets to to be elected and of course
it's a very westernized thinking uh
Western model of thinking because in
both Russia and China who has public
support isn't really what determines who
becomes leader uh once they become
leader it's important for them to have
public support and they do things to
retain it but that isn't generally how
the person who who takes over the
country is picked yeah it's um I think
the first time that I really started to
understand how some of this occurs in
other countries that maybe are not as
Democratic uh as the United States is I
was reading Bill browder's uh book red
notice and in it he was basically
talking about Putin as a a business
adversary right or just another you know
businessman and then eventually kind of
walks through how uh the rise of power
and so it set me down this deep rabbit
hole and then in your talk actually uh
that everyone seems to be very receptive
to uh you talk about Xi Jinping and his
rise and kind of how his father was
actually uh uh really you know treated
poorly
um very poorly by uh the ruling class
and now all of a sudden Xi Jinping has
risen to be the leader of that class and
so that is not a story that is common uh
in the United States mainly because we
just have a different system and a
system that uh frankly probably would
not allow those individuals to be able
to rise in power because the tactics
they used uh are negated here in the
United States right
but also I don't think you how you'd
have a cultural revolution in which a
bunch of people are arrested and thrown
into jail right as well so I think
that's that's also a product of that
well it's funny because I remember a a
friend of mine in a now deleted tweet
but right when the pandemic started uh
he tweeted out something and he
basically said
um you know the lockdowns never could
happen in the United States because
people value their freedom too much and
then I remember a couple of months later
we were in the middle of the lockdown
and I said to myself I actually agreed
with the Tweet when he said it
right and here we are and so I do wonder
how much of the ideals the ethos many of
the things that people uh I think kind
of hold up on this uh a spotlight of the
United States when it's actually put to
the test do they really believe these
things are they willing to have the
individual personal sacrifice to uphold
them or is it something that you can
talk about in quote-unquote peace time
in good times but when the bad times
come humans are humans and they just
succumb to you know whatever the easiest
path is I think that's definitely true
but I think it's also partly about what
I said earlier which is if you don't
continue to talk
confidently about what western values
are then when it comes to a decision
like lockdown well
if we don't really believe in individual
liberty
then why not do a lockdown right if we
don't really talk about how you know
bodily autonomy is important I mean
people do interestingly those are the
same people that demanded vaccine
mandates when it came to it in many
places but if we don't really remember
that you know one of the core tenets of
of Western values is that the individual
is sacred and is empowered to make their
own decisions about their own lives and
their own bodies and so on
uh then it becomes easier to sell people
on this sort of
um Collective action and I'm not saying
Collective action is always a bad thing
or always unnecessary you know if your
country gets invaded everybody has to
get together and fight right and of
course in the early stages of the
pandemic it was hard to tell what
exactly was going on but once we'd
allowed the government to instill the
fear of God into people by brainwashing
them through the media
um what's going on guys I hope you're
enjoying this conversation with
Constantine and I hate to interrupt but
Constantine said a couple of things that
YouTube doesn't like and so we've
decided to censor ourselves before
YouTube had the opportunity to take this
video down as I've mentioned in the past
we don't want to have to censor
ourselves but YouTube has rules that we
have to agree to and so I'm going to let
you all know every time that we get
censored right now Constantine is saying
something that YouTube doesn't like and
so this is my warning that yes you are
not seeing the full interview due to
those rules you'll probably see me again
later on in the conversation and I'm
sorry but that's just the way that the
game is played all right let's get back
into this conversation with Constantine
I hope you guys enjoy it
yeah that's kind of how people reacted
um and if you don't keep reminding
people that you know Freedom has
trade-offs like anything else we talked
about no Solutions only trade-offs
Freedom comes with Danger
and the United States was built by
people who believed that who understood
that and who were happy with that deal
right but if the more you move away from
from the way that your country was built
and founded because you forget your own
values and what it's built on the more
you're likely to import stuff from other
cultures you've got to understand I mean
lockdowns are not the sort of thing that
would have been created in the west it
is a product of a Communist party that
has complete control over its country
and they exported it everywhere and I'm
not is this isn't me spitballing here
Neil Ferguson who was the guy who was
largely responsible for the for
lockdowns and and our covert policy here
in the United Kingdom who later by the
way had to resign because he was
um visiting his mistress in the middle
of the very lockdowns that he encouraged
um
he said we didn't we didn't know it was
possible until the Chinese did it
it's crazy that that got exported like
that but I also think that there's a
number of ideas in society that have now
come from other countries and kind of
infiltrated the West and I think that's
one of your main points uh across your
your speech and then many of the things
that you talk about on a day-to-day
basis is if you have these Western
ideals and uh you know who you are which
is a key piece to it then it is easy to
identify that idea is not part of who we
are we do not actually accept that logic
but when all of a sudden that becomes uh
controversial to say I am an American I
am uh British I have these ideals I have
these ethos uh and you don't have the
identity uh in order to repel bad ideas
you kind of fall for anything right it's
the old adage of if you don't stand for
something you fall for nothing and I
think that's maybe your biggest message
uh that you continue to bring across all
of these different topics
I agree I I think that's right I think
that's where so many of our problems
come from is the inability to Define who
you are and the problem we have is less
the case in America thankfully but in
Britain like you come up to somebody and
you say what are British values
they're gonna look at you like you're
trying to you know catch them out or
make them look bad or give them an
opportunity to hang themselves on their
own rope because to even suggest that
there's such a thing as British values
that they should be defended you know
defined and maybe even defended this is
controversial stuff as you say and that
is crazy crazy
there's a gentleman Rob Henderson who uh
coined the term luxury beliefs and had
him on the show to talk about it yeah
amazing okay so uh this idea of luxury
beliefs uh when I heard you talking
about climate change and the fact that
the impact of climate change is going to
be determined by the poor countries or
the developing countries not necessarily
the most developed Nations uh that's the
first thing that jumped to my mind is
wow what a luxury it is for a developed
Nation to think that they can impact uh
this can you describe a little bit more
in terms of what exactly uh you're
looking for over the next couple of
years from the developing nations to
really determine how this will play out
well I don't think it needs to be as
complicated or not I just think it's the
universal constant human truth that
people want to live a better life than
they lived yesterday and they want their
children to live a better life than they
do and if you've got a population of one
point whatever billion in China and 1.4
billion in India a lot of whom are poor
they are going to be industrializing as
rapidly as they possibly can to deliver
economic growth and prosperity for their
people and by the way again it's not me
saying it you know I watch the Indian
oil Minister talking about this the
other day and he was being challenged on
why they're buying Russian oil and he
was like we have an obligation to our
consumer to provide energy like you know
they as I said in my speech they're not
of course look everyone who who believes
in climate change is concerned about its
impact and there are people in China and
people in India who are working on that
but the point is they are not going to
be sit there and go oh you guys spent
you know 200 years industrializing and
now we're just going to remain poor
because you we're all concerned about
climate change and so that's why I think
you know the solution to all of these
problems is going to be technological
and as we talked about right at the
start the West is best place to deal
with that yeah when you look forward are
there certain types of information
outside of uh uh kind of YouTube that
you really look for so one of the things
that I've uh looked at and struggled
with I think alongside many others is
every single one of these whether
they're geopolitical conflicts whether
they're things around uh uh mandates
whether they are things around the
vaccines and uh and uh covid or anything
else where do you get your information
how do you evaluate information you see
to actually know what is true or what or
what is worth putting weight to versus
uh it's either propaganda or it's
something that could even just be you
know some sort of person on Twitter
who's trying to get people riled up and
posting some random video from five
years ago like what is your process like
from getting information and really
vetting it
hey guys I hope that you're enjoying
this conversation as you probably
realize we don't run any ads on this
show that's right all the other podcasts
all the other YouTube shows that you
watch they have advertisers we don't
have any direct relationships with
advertisers and we simply create this
because we enjoy doing it now that we do
that though we have a team and if you'd
like to support us one way you can do
that is to go subscribe to the pop
letter it's a daily letter that I write
to about 235 000 people about my
personal opinion on financial markets
business technology and Bitcoin just go
to pompletter.com and you can sign up
there I'd love to have you join us and
it's a great easy way to support the
work that the team and I are doing on a
daily basis all right let's get back
into this conversation that's a really
good question and I think it's actually
something that everybody's struggling
with right now like there is no answer
really uh the one thing that I find and
for me the war in Ukraine was a very
interesting example of this because I
instantly saw people with whom I often
agree
who had no idea they could not find
Ukraine on a map
and initially they were all looking to
me to give them my view
right and they were like oh wow you did
that interview with Francis on
trigonometry you know it's you you've
got like half a million views or
whatever it was like great you know that
was fascinating thank you for this and
then two weeks later
they like had a narrative and it was
locked in
and they knew and they would argue with
like two weeks ago this guy was asking
me for my opinion now he knows better
than me what's happening in Ukraine so
if you watch people over time you can
see who like the the number one rule I
have is I try not to comment on things I
don't understand right so if you ask me
about something that I don't understand
I'll just say I don't know people who
comment on everything are largely going
to be unreliable sources of information
number one number two
and the problem we have as well is like
there's this meme online I don't know if
you're familiar with it which is I
believe the current thing and that's
kind of how like the people who think
they've got past the propaganda they
think that the people who still believe
the propaganda like brainwashed to
believe the current thing but there's
also this other thing which is I oppose
the current thing which is the exact
opposite like if the mainstream media is
saying it it must not be true well
that's not quite how it works so uh I
the way I've tried to do is I listen to
different people I see who who is a
reliable actor over time whose
predictions tend to be accurate and
who's not uh and that's kind of how I
get my information
I want to talk about Jordan Peterson and
Greta thundberg who I think uh represent
maybe two Extremes in the world
um and there's plenty of people who
disagree with one and like the other and
vice versa uh maybe we can start with
Greta uh I've seen you uh call her Saint
Greta of climate change uh obviously at
Oxford uh Peter Thiel uh had a number of
comments uh to say with about her as
well why do you think she has been so
effective in terms of becoming the face
and the voice of uh the climate change
movement
see you can't criticize that
interesting explain
well she's a child right so what you're
going to pick on a vulnerable autistic
child were you some kind of monster
right it's a very effective Shield
against criticism and discussion and
debate and if you think about what she
did it's not like she went around
educating people about the climate
that that wasn't her role her role was
to chastise people her role was to say
is to come back to the ideology that we
talked about earlier it's it's almost
like a religious cult uh you know
whether you and I'm not talking about
climate change I'm talking about the
ideology of Net Zero and reducing
consumption and all of this stuff right
because climate change is a separate
thing that's a scientific matter how you
deal with it is also a scientific matter
but it's also a matter of logic like as
I said in my speech if we produce two
percent of global carbon emissions
doesn't matter if we turn the lights off
and never turn them again it's not turn
them on again it's not going to make any
difference right so the fact that people
are demanding that we make ourselves
really poor all of a sudden that is not
a rational demand
that is not a rational thing and how do
you get people to do irrational things
well you can't persuade them rationally
so you have to emotion blackmail
whatever it is right
and a child who is upset and crying on
stage is the perfect method by which to
achieve that emotional impact right so I
have no issue with Greta tomberg herself
I think she's a a child that has been
badly let down by her parents and other
adults around her who have encouraged
her to go down this path which I think
in the end will turn out to have been
quite harmful for her I'm afraid
um so that's my my take on her I just
think she's she's being used by people
for their own political purposes I um
saw the video of her being arrested and
I'll kind of put that you know maybe an
air quotes uh and what I think surprised
me was not
her or others trying to get photo ops I
think that most of the times we see
content I always ask myself you know why
are we seeing this and why now right and
uh actually it was more so the
participation of the police I I think I
was saying to myself you know what is
going on are those real police officers
right why are they doing this why are
they participating
um and so I don't know if you have any
thoughts there in terms of uh you know
what seemed to be kind of photo op made
you know situations but it was also with
what appears to be real police officers
like do you ever read on that
no not really I I don't know enough
about it to be honest yeah the other
thing that you did as I mentioned was
you wrote a piece on why they hate
Jordan Peterson uh and he seems to be on
the opposite end of the spectrum uh from
a Greta thundberg in terms of at least
society's uh response and and also I
think uh a certain type of individual
who is drawn to that message why do they
hate Jordan Peterson
there are many reasons of course there's
always it's not a one thing but uh I
think that
um
look I I need to preface this because
it's important because
the the the short The Cliff Notes
version is they hate him because he
wants men to be better
and he has a positive message for men
but I don't believe that like
I don't believe that the answer for men
is to whine and complain
right so I'm not into like men's rights
movements because I just don't think
more than anything else I don't think
they're effective forget about how they
behave and the morality and whatever I
just I don't think people uh you know
we're biologically different and we're
programmed to have sympathy for women
and we're programmed to consider men
disposable uh that is the biologic
biological reality you're not going to
change it uh men creating movements
where they protest and complain about
the rights isn't going to change
anything uh men just have to be better
and work harder and uh you know look
after their own interests um
and uh one of the things about the
interest of men is is to find women who
want to be with them uh and who who
don't hate men right that's really how
you you solve that problem at an
individual level but uh the reason that
hey Jordan Peterson is he came out and
he unapologetically uh wanted men to be
better he wanted everyone to be better
and that's one of the other reasons they
didn't like him of course
um but also he challenged the ideology
and if you the reason I say this people
will think I've been sort of
conspiratorial or whatever but if you if
you cast your mind back to like the
Kathy Newman
interview and all of that they all she
did also an interview for GQ with a
woman called Helen Lewis who's
interviewed me and that they all all I
don't remember if she asked him this
specifically but lots of other
journalists all kept saying to him yeah
but the majority of the audience are men
what is that you know like like it was a
bad thing
no one goes to a Cosmetics company and
says the majority of the audience are
women why is that
because there's nothing wrong with women
but there's something wrong with men in
their world view uh and we you know we
hear it in the language of wokeness you
know you're just a straight white man
you're a toxic toxic masculinity or
toxic this toxic that and I think the
reason that Jordan Peterson came under
attack is because not only uh was he
trying to tell men and women but
particularly meant to be better he also
embodied traditional masculine virtues
uh that that people don't want to see
men exhibit in the world
what do you think like the one or two
top uh masculine attributes are that
people don't want to see
confidence strength
right someone who's not going to back
down someone is gonna uh you know fight
his Corner uh all the way again people
because people are stupid I have to say
this is I'm not saying women can't be
strong and confident right but but we
don't like to see Men Express those
things if you look at movies if you look
at television shows if you look at
stand-up the guy is always the Goof the
idiot the this that it's weak pathetic
and the woman is the the girl boss and
whatever that's what apparently we these
people want to see
um so the they didn't want to see a guy
who would come along and go actually no
you're wrong about that and I'm gonna
I'm gonna make the argument and I'm
gonna argue the case and I'm gonna
persuade you and if you don't agree with
me well you're wrong like they don't
want to see that they wanna they wanna
attack him and then for him to back down
yeah it is interesting that you
mentioned movies I think there's been a
very very big difference between uh even
people who are cast uh for certain uh
roles uh but the story lines of many of
these movies right you start to see I
always joke like the movie version of
the mannequins inside of the store where
they used to be uh would essentially
look like ripped you know models and now
they've got dad bods and uh that
celebrated to a degree you also are
starting to see some of that in movies
um where the you know hero or whatever
uh actually doesn't look or act the same
way that they would have 10 15 20 years
ago uh definitely not 50 years ago and I
do wonder how much of that uh is
programming children's mind who then
will grow to be adults uh and has a
long-term Impact versus nah they watch a
movie and then they go and they see you
know a sports star on television where
it can't be faked like you you can't be
fat and be in the NBA right for the most
part like you you have to be an athletic
person who is able to uh actually
accomplish the tasks on Williamson who
Zion William Zion yeah Zion William said
like he's a he's a chunky chunky chunky
guy I was just trying to make a joke uh
no he would he would say that he he is
muscular without the definition
mate he's probably way more more
athletic than me so I'm just joking uh
don't don't hit me Zion but um uh I I
know what you mean look uh we I mean the
media the Hollywood the powerful
machines for communicating stereotypes
to people right that's that's what it's
about and if all you see uh when you're
growing up is men who are weak and
pathetic then people are going to take
that message to heart now of course some
people will rebel against that
um but My worry is not only that it's
also like uh and I talk about it this in
my sub stack about Jordan why the hey
Jordan Peterson is like I don't know if
you've noticed this
but there's been an explosion in people
going to the gym specifically to look
buff not to like be healthy or whatever
but to like look buff like it's it's a
look thing for a lot of people and and
my view on it is and again it's
something I just it's a theory I'm not
saying this is necessarily true but it's
the one area where men are still allow
it to express authentic masculinity like
you are allowed to go to the gym and
lift weights that's not toxic not yet
there will be a time when that becomes
toxic as well uh right and they they're
already articles about how going to the
gym and being healthy is right wing like
they're already writing them
um but but it's it's the one area where
men can go and be men and show up in the
world as men
um and I think that's why it's kind of
displaced masculinity and that worries
me to some extent don't get me wrong the
gym is healthy Jim's gray exercise gray
lifting's great all of that stuff is
great
but some people now think that to be a
man is to look like a man and that is
not what to be being a man is about at
all being a man is about how you carry
yourself in the world what kind of
father you are what kind of husband you
are what impact you have on the world
what kind of leader you are these are
the things that make a man a man uh you
don't uh you don't have to be I'm not
saying it's bad I'm just saying you know
that can't be the only place that men
Channel their energy to be masculine
like that energy that people spend going
to the gym you might want to spread that
around a bit in terms of some other
things that's all I'm saying
the last thing I want to talk to you
about uh is Bitcoin and actually we
haven't talked about this so I have no
clue if you know anything about Bitcoin
if you're interested in it at all uh but
a lot of I think your view of the world
aligns pretty closely with people who uh
are interested or or uh use Bitcoin have
you spent any time on it do you have any
thoughts there around the asset
yeah so I pull uh iBall
half a Bitcoin
in like
about 2010 maybe something like that
I I don't remember when I bought half a
Bitcoin when at the time it cost me
about 400 pounds so it's about 600 okay
so and then probably 2012 2013-ish time
uh although I'm not a currency converter
expert yeah yeah and I I only bought it
because like people were talking about I
was like let's throw an amount of money
I don't you know I'm not gonna miss uh
at it and then it like doubled in price
a few years later I was like oh great
and I sold it so I got you know I got uh
I got twelve hundred dollars back for it
uh obviously regret that now
um but I'm afraid I'm gonna trigger you
and your entire audience uh by saying
that uh
I don't know I'm not an expert I'm not
qualified uh so I'm not saying this is
my like professional opinion or anything
like that
I get the feeling that this is a giant
scam and pyramid scheme that's going to
collapse very soon that's just my
feeling I I don't have any great
explanation of it uh I mean I I I can
explain some of it to you if you want
but yeah that's my sense of it so it's
fascinating to hear this um I've had a
couple people come on uh who
have similar ideas and talking through
it actually the audience uh really
enjoys so I'd love to hear uh kind of
why you think uh that or kind of what
are some of the data points maybe that
that have kind of built up in your mind
that that's led to it
in early 1990s Russia
um you got to think you've got a
communist system let's just collapse you
don't have a free market economy you
don't have advertising on TV for
products everything's brand new like
imagine you just like you popped out of
the womb straight into like a capitalist
world that's kind of how it was
and we had this thing called Triple M
and every day there would be an advert a
commercial on TV they'd be like oh I
bought this Triple M thing uh and it's
doubled in price you know I said to my
friend go and get it and he got it and
it's doubling price as well and we're
making loads of money and like that
continued for a long time
um and my dad who who was financially
literate I kept saying from Dad Dad
we've got to buy some of this and he was
like son this is going to collapse watch
and of course eventually it did it was a
giant pyramid scheme I'm not saying that
Bitcoin in and of itself doesn't have
value because I think that the
technology itself may turn out to be
quite useful in fact it almost certainly
will do but when I you know what I see
like out there when I turned open my
phone and I scroll Twitter or whatever
is like a hot girl going why don't you
invest in crypto you know like there is
a big industry now around pushing people
to buy this as a way to make money and I
fundamentally don't believe that you can
make you know I believe that money is
produced by contributing and creating
something productive right
Financial speculation is financial
speculation right so if you're playing
Bitcoin as like a stock you go you know
it might go up as well as go down
cool then you know what you're doing
you're gambling in the great Casino of
life and that's fine
but is it something that's going to
generate value uh I'm very skeptical
about that
um and we just did an interview which we
haven't released yet but we will be with
a guy called Mike Green he used to be
Peter Teal's personally you're familiar
with him Mike Green and I have had many
debates in public on this topic so he's
uh he's the perfect person to get the
other side of uh of the perspective
right right well I I have to say I've
I've listened to both sides of the
argument now listen man I I want to
remind people what I just said I don't
understand this area I'm not an expert
and I put that up front right but I'm
more persuaded by his argument than the
other argument so there's two I think
main things that uh I would kind of
respond with that
um again maybe it won't change your mind
but but I think are important to
understand so uh the first is um when
you think of the crypto industry there's
like 20 000 of these tokens at this
point right I think one of the big
points is like Bitcoin is very separate
than the other 1999 right everything I
said I was just I can be applied to
Bitcoin in my opinion so okay that's
what I mean okay so I think it applies
even to bitcoin but all the other tokens
even more so yeah correct definitely do
the other tokens and when it comes to
bitcoin I think there there's two you
know kind of fundamental things that I
believe and and I think many people in
the Bitcoin Community believe the first
is the idea of like the production of
money right so one of the things that
obviously has driven uh uh Fiat
currencies and these National currencies
uh or central banks and the centralized
control and there's a reason why they do
it and kind of how they run the economy
when you separate money from the state
in terms of Bitcoin uh you need
something to replace those organizations
right and so what has essentially a
replace it is uh kind of a two-step
process one there is a programmatic
monetary policy that's coded that can't
be changed by anyone and two is you have
the miners who are helping to produce
the Bitcoin right they are securing the
network they are doing this it is now
the strongest computer network in the
world it's the most decentralized yada
uh and so I think that one of the things
that becomes really interesting is if
you think right now in the the world you
have in the United States a country
that's been experiencing six seven eight
percent compounding inflation now for
multiple years UK very similar all
around the world you also have things
like the debt limit in the United States
where people are saying hey U.S
treasuries I thought were the safest
asset now you know I don't think the us
is going to default but there's some
hysteria here maybe I should go seek out
something else and then you also have
people around the world who say you know
what I just want something that I can
use and if you go to the extreme and you
look at Venezuela or Zimbabwe right if I
can't actually get US dollars because
it's dangerous or they're going to get
confiscated the next best thing is to
get something where I can just simply
hold on to it right I have sovereignty
over an asset and so just as you had
mentioned earlier that almost there's
this like luxury belief in the developed
world around uh climate change and some
of these things I actually believe that
there is this luxury belief around money
in the developed world and there's this
gentleman Alex Gladstone who should you
should have on the show uh he is at the
human rights foundation and he talks all
the time about uh Financial privilege so
if you or I go to the bank or to the ATM
we're able to easily get money out we
can send money right no one is trying to
stop us from doing that or confiscate
our assets but there are many places
around the world where that's not
necessarily true and that's where kind
of Bitcoin as a pure technology forget
about the speculation on that pure
technology has uh has value for those
individuals now how big is that market
uh how pervasive will that be will those
people eventually get to financial
privilege all up for debate
when it comes to the financial
speculation I actually think uh you
you're 100 right and I would agree with
you people who are using this to Simply
get rich uh probably will end up uh
being hurt because you have an asset
that uh the world does not yet know what
the value is Bitcoin thinks uh Community
thinks it'll be worth a lot more in the
future Bitcoin Critics on Mike Green and
others believe it'll be worth way less
in the future and so naturally you have
a market there will be volatility and so
the speculators usually end up getting
run over similar to I think the Triple M
that you described in Russia and so the
one piece that I think I'll leave you
with um when it comes to bitcoin uh is I
actually think you're a bitcoiner maybe
you just haven't realized it yet in that
I look at Bitcoin personally and I say
Bitcoin to me has taken the American
ethos and ideals things like free speech
and codified it right it is the ability
for anyone to send economic value to
anyone else without asking permission of
a third party uh it allows for a true
free market asset that is traded 24 7
365 with no internet mentioned from
external sources and then I think the
third thing is it allows for individuals
to have private property rights in a
technological sense uh in a digital
world which as we know if you compare
Russia China and other communist
countries private property rights are
incredibly important for the foundation
of capitalism democracy Etc and so what
I try to separate is like the asset from
the price because I think price like
I've been a fool in the past just as
much as anyone else and been like oh I
think the price is going to go up or
down or sideways or whatever you're
always wrong but when you look at the
actual technology it's almost as if they
were able to take these ideals which I
think you and I probably agree
vehemently on and say okay let's put
them into a piece of technology and now
go ahead and allow anyone in the world
to access it so I don't expect to change
your mind but I do think that there's
these elements of what you believe that
actually are codified in Bitcoin and if
you can separate out price from
technology then I think the technology
piece kind of resonates and and fits
nicely with many of the things you've
talked about today
well I I think some of that makes sense
to me uh I I suppose and look we've had
safety Amos on the show to talk so like
we've had the pro and anti-bitcoin case
I'm just saying I'm more convinced by
the I mean the financial speculation
part of it troubles me but but also you
know I spent quite a bit of time in
third world countries I don't see anyone
using Bitcoin there to you know I mean
there are people using Bitcoin now but
like I'm not walking around and like
Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin everyone's like
talking about it and using it to
transfer money and stuff like that uh it
may you know if once you have
infrastructure maybe that that will be
what happens with it
um and in terms of I'm I would separate
you know I may agree with the values of
Bitcoin that doesn't mean the values of
Bitcoin are reality in the sense that
I mean again this is a very low res
version of what people say but like you
know private property in the government
isn't you know you can do whatever you
want with your money the government is
not gonna come on death and taxes man
you know the government is going to find
a way to screw you that's what the
government's job is the government's job
is to find you and to take some of your
money that's what that that's what they
do best yeah well I think that uh Nuance
to that right is like in America we have
private property rights but still the
government gets paid taxes the
government still prevents you from doing
certain things and and all that it's
more so
um what it allows for you to do is have
the private property right in the
digital realm right before Bitcoin there
really was no way to have kind of the
private property rights so I I do think
that this is a actually a really really
important point because uh many people
look at the Bitcoin community and they
hear private property rights as an
example like oh they're all anarchists
they all want to take down the
government and I actually think as I've
you know met many many people in the
community they're like no no I actually
believe in the United States I believe
in democracy I believe in capitalism I
believe in all this and that's why I'm a
bitcoiner right is that these private
property rights I think are going to be
essential and some of them will even go
as far as and say look I think that the
governments will need this asset uh as
we get kind of deeper and deeper into
these debt cycles and things like that
again all Up For Debate
um I know that you've got to run so I
don't want to keep you much longer uh
where can we send people to find you
online and also to pick up your book if
if they're interested
uh well first off before we do that I
should just say uh I enjoyed hearing
your take on it and I'm always open
particularly on things I don't know
anything about to hear different sides
and and get new information so I really
enjoyed that part of our conversation uh
in terms of uh everything else the book
is called an immigrants love letter to
the West you can get it on Amazon uh
read my sub stack just search for my
name Constance and kiss and sub stack
and uh the Youtube show is trigonometry
it's also available as a podcast on
Spotify and everywhere else those are
the things that I do and I I really
appreciate having me on Constantine I
really appreciated this conversation I
learned a lot
um and uh frankly I think there's a lot
of people around the world who uh not
only appreciate your message but also
the way that you deliver the message so
please keep it up uh and we will
definitely do this again in the future
fantastic thanks for having me